short question short answer is here
drilled as a proper list of course he is
is proud of that magnetra nama explains
why he's not well if he is a populist
then all politicians are in that sense
that they all pretend to represent the
people they all pretend that the people
are really actually they really
represent the people better than their
opponents and this is why there are
elections now you are right in the sense
that that had published also strongly
opposed the political elite but on the
other hand there is also this notion of
populism being just to say what the
people want and and if you can say one
thing about builds it's not that he just
says what people want he in fact has
taken fairly in popular positions in in
a certain in a certain number of the
domains but the way Islamophobia is
framed is in such as such that you
cannot really criticize or approach
problems and I give you one we have in
our Institute investigated the
radicalism among Dutch Muslims it turns
out that twelve percent of the Moroccan
people in Holland reject democracy want
Sharia and is support violent means to
introduce the Sharia this is due this is
true for eight percent of the Turkish
people now the good news is that most of
these
people are elderly met mill fairly
uneducated who are not willing to do
something about it so there's no problem
so the conclusion the conclusion of my
colleagues on till he was there was not
really a problem for democracy but is it
true that people who take such result
seriously and say there is a problem are
Islamophobic no I don't think you can
say that it depends on what is it
Islamophobia one becomes criticism
phobic well first of all I think if you
address a group as a group with that you
are wrong because you're part of the
group or you are wrong because you are a
Muslim if you address a problem whether
it's with immigration whether it's with
housing whether it's worth identity and
I think it's interesting that you come
up with this example because that was
exactly my point that one of the major
issues whether it's within a migrant
societies or communities or whether it's
in non ligon is a question of identity
look at why populace so much stress the
fact that the Dutch society has to
become more Dutch we are and not only in
Holland we are really in search of what
does it mean to be a citizen what does
it mean to be Dutch what does it mean
that I have a Dutch Passport and what
does the European community has to say
about that these are the real issues and
they live in an immigrant community as
much as in another and I'm sure that
this question you you address is a
question of a problem of a challenge of
identity and that's what we should
address yup clink yeah just just I think
it's a very important place a question
what does it make is the foam
Islamophobia I don't think that if
someone who's in Parliament like here
the others discusses the fears and
actually she has the fears of the people
that this in itself is wrong I'd rather
say it's very good
he does reflect the fields which are in
society it depends on the answers you
gave and the answer that has been given
is actually that the group itself is
unrepairable and so Islam in itself will
will and shall be a problem now and it
will be in future and also the fact that
he is not only reflecting the fears but
he is in my opinion and certainly
exploiting fears because he doesn't give
a solution it just says they have to go
back we have to get less of them no mass
migration anymore although we don't have
mass migration and in the at this very
moment so that's what i mean by
exploiting the problem and so I think
that someone in who is a politician
needs to reflect the fears of the people
but the answer you give it depends on
the answer you give weather is s llama
phobia like for certain of previous
session or whether it is what I always
very much likened in a German culture if
they speak about Hoffman's triggers
those who try to be able to hand off to
the people solutions and okay now well
can you explain why wielders is so
popular at this moment well as I try to
say in my introductory statements many
people are worried about mass
immigration in particular of people who
are coming from non-western countries
and although it is may be true to say
that at the moment there is no mass
immigration I don't have the figures
here it is certainly true that in the in
the in the 90s of the last century there
was mass immigration I know it's quite
well because I was leading their
favorite day that those in those days
and we had to work with it and it is my
conviction that if the people who then
had political power in the latter part
of the 80s and the beginning of the 90s
in the second half of the 90s if those
people and I mean lovers and coke from
me lo and
if they had it had adopted a stricter
policy on immigration restricting
immigration to people who could who
could who could be of benefit to the
Dutch economy as mr. clink once then we
would not have had all the problems that
we have now and we probably would not
have a mystery illness as we have now
his existence is a it's a reaction to do
a situation we have gone out of hand and
unhooked oleander to hug thank you Paul
face completely this is our fresh
individual mr. Bach Stannis is perfectly
right because big problem in the
Netherlands until now is that we always
concentrated on integration and not on
migration we should have developed a
migration politics and we never had it
we always call a concentrated torts of
cultural interpretation of the
Netherlands and integration be it
multiculturalism or be it perfect
xenophobia the thing we should ask this
who is welcome and who is not and on
what grounds and that is a confrontation
with ourselves because that makes
perfectly clear that the question who is
welcome in our country is first and last
a political question which cannot be
answered in moralistic terms but which
can only be asked be answered in
political terms and that is quite
confronting for a country which always
identified itself on the basis of morals
or values of being a good country
because migration politics by definition
is about exclusion and not about
inclusion it is about exclusion and we
should be harsh but because it's the
only answer you can give to that to that
question secondly if we look at
liberties
i would say freedoms in a liberal
democracy and a state of law that we r
is the Liberty to do stupid things as I
a burn and put it so the concept of
Liberty cannot be connected by the state
with a specific interpretation of what
you should do with these liberties so
the connection between liberties on one
hand and a concept of emancipation on
the other hand is utterly wrong because
there is a fundamental right not to be
emancipated and that is why the left has
so much trouble I sensed it in the end
the debate of the former panel and in
some respects I thought there was a sort
of assumption that civilization is left
I don't think so I don't think so okay
civilization has left well I wanted to
and that the discussion about mass
immigration I'm I always wonder how you
could mr. Baucus and how you could say
something like that that it all comes
that Vilnius is born out of our out of
the mass immigration that took place in
the last 50 years what I would ask you
don't you think is it's much more a
question that we cannot address the
issue of how the Dutch culture what it
means in a bigger European context for
instance that people are afraid of
losing something and they think they
lose it because foreign people come to
this country they don't even exactly
know what they lose but they feel
something is
lost something that was cozy and
familiar and that has to cut that has to
be lost because obviously so many
foreigners come in today and I think
you're making the same mistake by not
looking deeper the underlying issue why
are we so afraid of losing something and
what is that and how can we address that
issue when I certain think that people
have voted for hit villas out of a host
of different motives and certainly the
what you are describing is present among
those motives people are unhappy for
various reasons they've lost their job
their wife has run away a girl there
girl is on the drugs and so on and so
forth and that makes them unhappy and
disgruntled and therefore they think
well what the hell I'll vote for head
rulers that that that that is certainly
true but the but the end what you
mentioned at the loss of cultural values
and so on that that used to be the case
via video European Union people used to
be against European Union because they
thought well our culture would disappear
this great big a jamboree of different
different culture so so that is
certainly present but Vilnius has
latched on to that unhappiness if you
like which in this case goes back to the
mass emigration of the 90s that is when
when it happened and that is when it
went wrong and it went wrong because the
government of the day will still
impressed with this idea of the hood of
handling of the good stranger and
therefore was ineffective in controlling
the influx in our borders it it it fell
down on his duties and illness is a
clever politician so then he makes use
of that and he becomes very popular for
a while for a while let's see what
happens the next election so that is
behind it but what he says about Islam
is normal
we have a country and we have freedom of
religion it is in fact the basis of the
Netherlands goes back to the dr yahoo
allah has the basis of the netherlands
so statements like we must forbid the
Quran or whatever he eats as in that
direction is simply nonsense